they think I sound smart it sounds smart
because it's simple it's present voice
it's active not passive the body was
carried out of the room we carried the
body for its simple defenses so now like
have been would have been carried it's
just we carried no adverbs usually
adverbs are placeholders for shitty
verbs we shut the door really hard we
slam the door very super way that
condenses it down short sentences so
simple sentences almost always Max one
comma for the most part and whenever you
have like two comma like it's like blah
blah comma comma and then the thing
usually you can just rip it out or
reframe it so there's just one sentence
and then again the vocab is under third
grade ideally fifth grade tops